Oh as you can see i bought these for 11
589 and there's about 100 k margin on
however they end suppose a little a
little strange definitely a little
little scared about that they didn't in
survive but to insta sold so I'm
guessing someone just had to and happen
to dump both the same time however those
who sell their won't be up 100k and we
can continue to do more it's kind of
depressing but I haven't been going as
hard on the merch account lately I don't
know why it's just cuz I kind of had bad
luck with certain merges and it's really
about it but I'm gonna check out some
other things as you can see I left these
in overnight luckily they sold if not be
kind of pissed off because every time it
seems that I by heavy boluses or zentai
chores but they're always good merchants
they just crash so I don't know it's
just my luck I guess but oh I went to
sleep in hopes of buying these things as
you can see i bought them i bought one
for 6.5 mill and bought the rest for six
point one three five so I'm hoping I can
oh my god I might be able to sell these
on please tell me I can please tell me I
can as you can see one of the Rings
ended up selling over another one did
buy for 550 que les so I'm going to try
and throw these up I'm going to lower
the price just a little bit just to make
sure or try to make sure that they do
actually sell well as you can see one of
these sold i bought back one 46.2 mel
and these haven't sold so they probably
dropped as expected however i did get a
lot of money out of the two that did so
so that's pretty good well this was
weird so basically I saw someone at the
GE saying selling black fur gloves of
darkness 500k so I was like [__] what do
they buy for what are they so forth so
bought one for 500k and then sold it on
for 1.4 mil more rings have sold as you
can see so of Soloff two more so we just
need to wait for these shoes so well
torture or torture ornament kit just
bought 20 1.4 mm I don't know what the
[__] to sell it for though a torture
ornament get sole 21 1.875 quick 500k
profit on that there we go so two of the
alight blisters have sold and probably
going to re put an offer
and hopefully be able to buy some for a
pretty low price from what it looks like
they actually dropped overnight to about
where my offer was so I happen to
probably I think just get lucky enough
to be able to grab them some thrown an
offer for this maybe can I get three
know only too well went back to bed and
two of them have bought however no more
soul which kind of depressing hopefully
I don't get stuck with these but we
already made a little bit of money off
of it so it's not exactly the worst
sinner it'll be in I think I'm just
gonna have to lower it a little bit and
check out the guide price on OS buddy
and os buddy does not have a guy pricing
off for so one of my life boluses has
bought it pretty much instaboy this one
of these sold so I put an offer in less
than a minute I ended up buying another
one so I'm just gonna throw this back in
45 5 99 k simple enough all of my light
Bliss's have sold don't know what they
really buy for right now am I trying to
do them again though since I am buying
these and then probably will be going to
sleep soon so they might be able to get
a good margin the guy brace on OS buddy
said to listen for 4.3 mill and
apparently they had stuff off for 4.43
so I lost somebody k on him but I'm not
too upset about it I think it would have
dropped more if I kept him in overnight
well just came home before I'm going to
go to bed have a blister bought and then
one tube set up sell it in for 5.45 mill
and it sold for 5.55 instantly so that's
insane well hopefully this merch goes is
expected as you can see 170 k margins on
heavy ballistas so this should be like a
510 K profit but really 340 since I
bought them for a little higher than
that the actively traded price is a lot
higher but I don't think they'll sell
for that so I'm just going to throw them
in for 10 199 and hope for the best and
there we go two of them a soul will buy
back another two and just keep on doing
this for a little bit why not and the
last one has sold me to a bond so look
at that look at this and non-stop merges
bro just look at this two more two more
we're making tons of money office I'm
height both of these are sold there we
go came on in the morning did a few
merges and as you can see all the light
Bliss's have sold however no more bought
so we're just gonna we're just going to
get away from that real quick up to 40
which is kind of nice well two of these
heavy boluses have sold um I bought one
initially for that and it said I could
make a 90 k profit however I was able to
make what did i buy them for yeah I
guess I was able to make about the
Prophet it said I was um I thought I was
making more of a profit apparently only
about 90 k had to drop the price however
they did silk so probably gonna move on
to something else because this wasn't
that great of an item i could flip a
couple more but i think there's better
items to be had the types of people i
just cannot stand in this game and this
dude just comes up under me I obviously
was in this world you can see old chat
log and the game log of me being a crack
in one to go back came back and the
seeds like really and so by saying
really he implies that you should be
respectful and hop out of his world
because it's his at least as far as he
knows and I said I was banking and he
says [__] [__] and then I was like
nice man real classy so this shoots
obviously just a huge [__] [__]
but he tries to act like he's the
[__] victim if I hop back in this
world [__] like that pisses me off man
alright so something a little different
here um so I was like what kind of like
type of fishing thing could i do i just
typed in fish and I saw bra angler fish
I was like all right let's give this a
shot basically what i saw was that
there's no one buying him i put i could
have put an offer for three coins and i
would have had the highest by offering
which is really weird but i also saw
that the price was 1,600 the guy price
right now is 1850 an angler fish
themselves are always pretty steady at
around not 1.9 k so i felt like there
was really no risk going into this so as
you can see i just bought pretty much
10k at 5th or 1555 and i should be able
to sell them on at around 16 86 so
around 1700 baby so i think i think i
might have made like two middle off of
this let's see what we can try to sell
all this for alright so as you can see
the guide price is 1820 i'm just going
to try to put them in for 1802
and hopefully they'll sell for that if
they do we'll be at 19.3 with that if
you add on the coins i already have will
hit the 44 mill mark this episode which
i have no clue if that's going to work
but I sure as hell hope it does
meanwhile on the main look at that try
then the Seas full 439 Casey that's lit
1.5 mil that's so nice to have just free
room it's man that's great alright so as
you can see I've sold off 2.4 k worth
however i just bought a raw anglerfish
to see with the buy price was currently
going for what if i had to up my by
offer and set yourself up there they're
buying for 1800 which would be to GP
below what i sold at so i'm just going
to do this real quick and see how many
on they will sell insta sold all of them
for 1800 would you believe that all
right nice 3k why not throw them in for
18 under as well one GP under and all of
those as well look at the hat so I'm
gonna take out its offer for a little
bit and as you can see we are up to 43.8
millets insane that was such a good
merch I don't know if that was just the
timing but uh might try that again the
future a little different little
different um decided to do some
tyrannical rings don't know what the
tyrannical ring is gonna buy it so I may
just buy one before i go to sleep um i
guess we could check it out might as
well um [__] i don't know so a little
different so we got four tyrannical
rings and to bliss is buying and to
selling one has actually sold so i'm
going to try and listen sup 44 or 45 mil
499 k and hopefully those will sell
overnight if they do indeed but we'll be
getting 22 mill and we bought them all
collectively for 21.3 so we'll make 700k
on that and these like ballistas i'm
going to put an offer for another one
and hopefully they'll buy they're really
cheap right now for some reason they
actually had a huge fight recently some
hoping for the best on these a little
bit of background noise disregard that
however all these channel rings have
sold two of the light Bliss's have
bought and one has sold so that's pretty
good or
try to flip these light ballistas maybe
a little more maybe some trainer Corrine
its [__] it I don't know well as you can
see treasonous rings I'm currently
buying they have a 73 k margin which
isn't too bad ball of them by Miguel
500k the ring of the Gods it's guide
price was thirteen point like 35 so I
put in an offer for 13.5 which is what
the RS buddy says the buy price is an
instable for 13 point 05 so kind of
annoying but we're gonna try to make
some money off of it hopefully well
bring of the Gods has not sold only one
of the trees and strings but so I guess
it's somewhat undercut me on that that
is fine because I guess I'll make my
money back on the trees it's raining but
another like ballista has bought which
is kind of good I think they they seem
like they'll be somewhat profitable so
we'll just run with these hopefully ah
oh well [__] guys I think it's gonna be
the end of the video I think I want to
start keeping them a little shorter cuz
13 minutes kind of a long video for
emerging video as you can see i sold the
ring of gods for about i think a hundred
que los and then the trees in the spring
i sold on for 40k profit one or actually
two of these like ballistas have sold
and three about 44.8 bill so we're going
to be leaving off the episode here we'll
just say that this is 10 mil in total 0
15 ml 15 mil let's just say that that's
probably right right yeah 15 mil so 15
mil in light ballistas and then we have
pretty much 32 m else around that 32
since we get the light Bliss's so we are
ending off this episode with a grand
total of forty-seven mill I hope you
guys enjoy to help it helped you out if
you guys have any comments feel free to
leave them down below anything I can
approve out any questions in general I
will be around to answer those if you
guys enjoyed the video feel free to
leave a like and if you guys want to see
more in the future make sure to
subscribe nonetheless hope you guys have
a wonderful day and also add me and game
if you want because I always love
talking to you guys
there we go so happy all peace out guys